has reddit promote freebooting the
answer to that in a way is yes
surprisingly for the last century media
has been behind a paywall if you wanted
to see something you'd have to open your
wallet as we know the model has changed
hours of content are being uploaded
every minute free for you to watch we've
seen Facebook videos spamming our feeds
those reddit links bringing us to some
bizarre ad ridden video sites and there
is one word for them freebooters so the
term freebooting isn't popularized
online lately mostly due to what's been
going on with Facebook when an artist
creates a work be it a song a picture or
a video and someone takes that work and
re uploads it to their own site without
credit or permission in order to promote
themselves that's freebooting when a
piece of media is uploaded directly to
facebook's video player it is heavily
favored over outside links due to the
fact that Facebook actually promotes
videos that have been natively uploaded
to Facebook more than it promotes
outside links these people are free
booting off of other people's work in
order to gain popularity and in many
cases that popularity equals profit so
Facebook's system is designed for one
thing and that's easy traffic generated
for them that is the Facebook ecosystem
it's also happening on reddit
what is reddit really you need me to
describe ok reddit is a URL aggregate
where certain links are voted up and
certain links are voted down basically
it's a great place to come and find
content of all shapes and sizes a few
days ago I was browsing Reddit and I
came across an animated gif from one of
our videos on the front page and this
was really cool and I was really
flattered to see people enjoying our
work but then I went on to read the
comments and I had a realization the
opie had not linked to our channel or
bothered to credit us in fact I had to
scroll all the way down to the bottom of
the comments thread to find a kind soul
who took the time to share a link to our
work it's common practice on reddit to
take a clip from a show or a video that
you like and create an animated gif and
share it with other people is this wrong
is this as bad as what's happening on
Facebook freebooting on Facebook and
reddit are incredibly similar except for
one major difference and that is I like
this video I download it Irie uploaded
that that's what reddit freebooting
generally is somebody makes a video and
then somebody takes the whole video and
compresses it into a gif and then they
post that on reddit that's technically
freebooting as well free booted content
on reddit
is a little less insidious than
Facebook's version on Facebook people
were directly profiting off of taking
credit for other people's work on reddit
the closest thing you get to turning a
profit is a couple reddit gold awards so
the intentions aren't nearly as
malicious we got to ask a hard question
does reddit and/or Facebook actually
promote freebooting also one would argue
that the post on reddit would help
expand the artists audience well the
problem is this is only true if the
artist is credited most artists like us
actually make most of our revenue
through ads in order for us to make that
revenue people have to come to our
YouTube channel watch the video ideally
maybe sing an ads skipping it or
something like that and we get a very
very small percentage of that ad revenue
naturally when somebody free boots the
video and reposted it on their site or
their page we don't see the ad revenue
therefore we lose out on paying
ourselves back for the time and energy
we've spent making the content let's say
the viewer watching the content wants to
see more or enjoys the artists work well
if it's free booted it's on an anonymous
page and the viewer can no longer figure
out what the source of the material is
but frankly if you do want to help
promote the artist the best you can do
is provide a URL or link to the source
material allowing viewers to directly
access it it comes down to the average
user to make a difference between Reddit
and Facebook if we never take the time
to cite a source or provide a credit
then we are cutting the artists out and
we are free booting off of the artists
efforts if you see someone ripping other
people's work tell them that they need
to credit the Creator after all if you
see a video or picture you like the best
thing you can give that artist is a
moment of your time to look at the rest
of their work in the end that's why we
make it for you to see it we don't need
to make rules or pass laws on this all
we need to do is encourage each other to
be aware of the artists behind the
content we enjoy that makes all the
difference between freebooting and
sharing
you